i've been living with drama i'm on my
knees
i've been kicking people off the apollo
stage for what 31 years if you're not
good enough you get booed off the stage
the audience love it
not so good
i'm cp lacy the executioner at the world
famous apollo theater all together now
welcome to the apollo amateur night are
you ready
amateur night at the apollo is the
granddaddy to all of these shows that
you look at today x factor america's got
talent american idol you come and you
sing or you dance or you do your magic
or tell a joke a poem and the audience
will decide whether you go on to the
next level
or whether you get booed off of the
stage that's where i come in
[Music]
my role is to educate you about your own
talent or lack thereof
our booing policy is this there's a boo
here a boo there a boo here then the
booze just get paramount we have a noise
meter backstage and when it reached a
certain boo level the next thing you
know there's a siren
enter the executioner to kick you off of
my stage
[Applause]
the executioner character changes after
every execution at the top of the show
i'll gong someone off as michael jackson
you've been hit by you've been struck by
a boo criminal the godfather of soul
james brown so true
so true you just got a boo
hey hit me prince
boom
the apollo theater is a place where we
as african-americans could go and
perform folks like ella fitzgerald sammy
davis jr james brown and lauren hill
have graced the apollo stage
i don't enjoy kicking people off the
stage per se if time allows i try to get
to the person who got booed off the
stage and just encourage them and
console them go back to the woodshed
learn your craft and come back and when
you're very very good we'll give you the
claps the apollo always invite you to
come back and try again
[Applause]
every week without fail when they say
here's the executioner saying goodnight
to you folks thanks for coming in
there's always someone that goes boo
i hate you
they just love being a part of the
apollo audience
[Applause]
[Music]
you